Brady has been to really interesting historical site.
It is the site of the first nuclear reactor designed to
make plutonium.
It started operation in 1943 in the middle of the second world
war. The reactor is still there. There it's no longer operating.
I thought it was operating because there were three workers apparently working
on it. But then I realized that they were just models.
Brady thinks that's very funny.
So we are at Oak Ridge national laboratory,
and this is the site of the world's first continuously operated reactor.
You may recall that at Chicago,
a pile of uranium and graphite led to the first measurement of criticality.
What happened here was the design and construction of the first
purpose-built reactor to run continuously.
There were three paths to a nuclear weapon.
One of them was involved involved the production of plutonium,
which is an artificial element, which must be produced in a nuclear reactor.
This reactor was built to demonstrate that process.
It was a project led by farming.
The design was principally done by Eugene Wichner,
who was a Nobel prize winner who led research to the lab for a number of years.
And by Alvin Weinberg, who was the director of the lab for a number of years.
Exactly three days after Hiroshima,
I'll be 29 and set out for Nagasaki at 10 58, the morning of August 9th,
the bomb was exploded above the city. And in the towering mushroom,
Japan could read its doom.
This is the face of the reactor.
This is where the fuel lodge would be inserted after they were in the
reactor for a sufficient length of time,
they were then pushed out the other end.
They dropped into a pool and were drug underwater to a chemical
plant where the plutonium was extracted.
You can see the rod that's actually used to push the rod,
but inside many of those holes would be an aluminum rod that has within it,
pellets of uranium because more and more rods go in.
What are we getting closer to? Well,
you have neutrons flying around and eventually what happens is that enough
neutrons hit uranium fuel that you split enough Adams. Each Adam,
you split releases two neutrons, and now you start getting multiplication.
Criticality means actually getting to that point where the multiplication is
enough to sustain the reaction when you kick them out. The other side, though,
it's not, you, haven't now got a broader, pure plutonium.
You have a log of a mixture of a lot of fishing products,
uranium that hasn't transformed.
And so you have to chemically separate all that. And that,
that is actually an art in itself. And that was done in a,
in a building adjacent to them.
Uranium has two isotopes atoms with different numbers
of neutrons in them. There's uranium two, three, five,
which is in quite small abundance about 0.7% and
uranium two, three eight, which is 99.3% abundance.
And this reactor worked on the decay of the
uranium two, three, five,
which generated the neutrons, which then dumbbell did the target.
This is your favorite room, isn't it?
Well, you know, I didn't control that. So this is the original control room.
This is where the reactor was controlled from.
This is obviously model number one of controlled rooms for reactors.
And it looks similar to what subsequent reactors from that
era would have looked.
And so these various controls would tell you about power level and about
radiation levels and the extent to which rods were inserted and
things that relate to the operation of the systems, like the cooling systems.
This was leading to the production reactors,
which were to be built and were built in Hanford Washington for the actual
production of kilogram quantities of platonic.
Why is it called a graphite reactor?
Cause you've been talking to me about uranium and plutonium.
Oh, the graphite is the moderator.
And so what you have to do is in the vision process,
you get two neutrons off, but the energy is wrong.
And the graphite is one of the means by which you can reduce the energy to
the range where you maximize the cross-section for the next vision.
So this is the actually the original log book from the day when the
reactor first went critical and family was actually here and he was called at
five o'clock in the morning because the researchers knew it was going to go
critical. And he came in and observed. The first criticality of.
As a scientist yourself is probably kept a few low books.
Do you look at that and feel a bit of excitement or.
Well, you know,
we all fill out lock log books and we all have this hope that maybe our
log book someday would get this level of attention.
So it's actually quite exciting to be here and see this.
This is at the mid plane of the reactor.
And that means that the neutrons that are coming out from the reactor are going
to come out horizontally.
And this is where the first neutron scattering measurement was done.
Now to give a little background,
we've got three ways of looking at the nanoscale or atomic scale properties of
materials. One is with the electron microscope. One is with x-rays.
And one that is probably not as well known is with neutrons and the
neutrons associated with this reactor,
which operates at thermal energies.
These neutrons have wavelengths comparable to the distances between atoms and
solids. So you actually can do the fraction experiments from solids,
which leads to different information than you would get with x-rays.
It leads to information on magnetism.
It leads to information on the dynamics of the motions of the atoms
and the first neutron scattering experiments were done here.
And that led to a Nobel prize for cliff shul who developed neutron
scattering in the forties and fifties at this laboratory.
I kept on wondering why they still had
this reactor there. My theory, I have no idea if it's right,
is that the reactor is still so radioactive inside that it's
easier to seal the outside and turn it into a museum than to work
out how to decommission it before all the radioactivity inside has
dedicated way.
This is the burst of the nuclear era from the perspective of the
scientific and technological application of neutrons.
And that has had a very important part and is the reason that Oak Ridge national
laboratory exists today because the fact that this reactor
existed after the war and this capability existed,
and it was important for isotopes and it was important for neutron scattering,
and it was important for materials irradiation and the development of nuclear
power is what led to the continuing of
the scientific effort here for peaceful purposes.
And that led to Oak Ridge national laboratory.
This is a special place to come in here often,
not often, but often enough to get rejuvenated.
[Inaudible].